well guys today's today and this is a
day that I have been waiting for longer
than I can even remember I mean it has
been so long I mean I did my first book
report I was like the second coming of
Steve Jobs and it was a book that
impacted me for so long all of the kids
that were in my class but like Justine
really would know what you're talking
about what's a Mac but today is the day
and we're at the Apple park campus and
we're here for the launch of whatever it
is that they're going to announce it's
the Apple event 2017 I was in San
Francisco not at the keynote for the
original iPhone in 2007 I was there for
Mac world this is a quick little clip of
the moment that I saw the first iPhone
and now here we are ten years later I'm
getting to go to my first Apple event
and I'm so excited I can't breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go check in and get the day
started
[Music]
okay checked in event didn't start for
another two hours but I don't know what
I'm gonna do hopefully I could find a
friend cuz I don't have any friends
right now so step one find it
so being honest with you I don't know
where I'm going I'm following these
people because they all look like they
know where they're going this is the
path up to of the Steve Jobs theater
this is the first event that is being
held here it's incredible
[Music]
behind me is pretty much exciting the
first iPhone and I wasn't actually in
the keynote but I was in San Francisco I
was at Macworld well
the iPhone it was there in 2007 but I
laid my eyes on this little guy and
little did I know that this phone would
change my life and not only has it
changed my life but has changed so many
other people's lives so to be here today
to celebrate the anniversary of the
original iPhone here at the Apple of it
at the first time ever an event is being
held at the Steve Jobs theater the first
person that I ran into when I stepped up
to the theater was Steve Wozniak and you
know it's one of those things like when
you meet your heroes we don't know what
to say I didn't know what to say but I
said thank you thank you for everything
and then he walked away so I'm about to
head in right now but first let's do a
360 tour of this incredible computer
[Music]
let's head in now I'd say this was my
first time in the theater but I did a
live stream entering it so we're here
now in the inside and downstairs is
where the action theater is so up here
is I'm not really sure what they're
calling this it's sort of like a bit of
welcome area but guess who else I just
ran into of course I'm excited this is
new everything is very new I mean this
is the Steve Jobs theater now you've
been to Apple events before yeah but
none of them have been here and this
building is new all this is new
we're gonna go downstairs soon before I
was right I couldn't find any friends
but the signing of a sentence what are
your expectations I expect to see new
iPhone but hopefully they do something
different hopefully have some new
product that one word thing could be
cool to bring back the one more thing
back to the Steve Jobs
my I didn't even think about that one
more thing let's hope for it this is my
actual first time ever holding
the original I thought great places to
do that first thing I did was split up
to today
and it just doesn't look real anymore
well it basically looks like a
stretched-out Apple watch or the Apple
watch is like a shrunken down version of
the original phone okay a little bit
there an above camera so small
eight gigs if I just download the whole
Spotify library including games
right
good I'm really excited are you excited
I'm not excited to hear it I haven't
cried yet though this is gonna be great
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
we're minutes away from the event
started are you hyped I am so excited
even though it's not saying I'm like
great stone cold here right now but I'm
surprised
[Music]
the event just ended and now we're going
into the hands-on station let's head
over there and take a look and see what
we can see
this entire open space was closed before
so these walls just opened up to reveal
hands-on demonstration
[Music]
it isn't I'm too
this is the iPhone 10 look at this it's
my baby
this is so weird with no like I don't
even know how to just like all I need
your face
sorry okay so I had to use someone
else's fancy so here I am obviously
we're going to scroll up and were going
to be the who emoji
this is a demonstration of their AR so
you can actually like walk around this
person so that basically right here on
the floor
natural light spotlight
we've been checking out so many things
and I just bought it a while Chris
tomorrow what do you think obviously I'm
excited what about you Oh
I mean iPhone 10 warming I mean it looks
like X but it's a 10 I mean that's
brilliant screen goes edge to edge it
looks amazing it's beautiful I'm
probably still gonna call it X but you
know I gotta yelled at like 50 times on
the floor they're like you gotta stop
sounds more mysterious iPhone X even
though we know everything about it now
it's true and I was so upset with some
of the rumored colors like that gold
color I was not a fan but this gold that
they have right now is perfect like I
absolutely love it i almost wish the ex
came in the gold but it doesn't it goes
back to the classic colors true that's
true well let's go check out some Apple
watch stuff I'm excited about the album
rolling in
it isn't
which I am wearing if the new app watch
series 3 its is the 42 millimeter and
this is the new gold color the blue in
color is called spicy orange I
definitely want this pink one too it's
like a pink leather peel shop it's
called fuchsia this just in
[Music]
should come in too
you feel the Rue
with joy
shame the world
outside just disease
so what did you think amazing I am super
excited for the 10 I keep calling it the
act but I'm like no no no it's the 10
well thanks helping me film like the
question of it is are you excited yeah I
know the option you have to use it but
like we got a taste and it's pretty
sweet
this is the Apple visitor center we're
gonna go inside and check it out I
thought earlier when I first got here so
now we're gonna go inside we'll be
eventually open to the public so you
guys can come in check it out do a
little bit of shopping ever really cool
VR station over here where you can take
a look using your phone using the
augmented reality and do a flyover tour
of a papyrus wonderful so here it is you
can use your iPad and this shows you
happy
oh wow even pretenders in the media
[Applause]
this is so awesome
so you guys ever get a chance to come
here when it's open to the public I
definitely recommend it because this
experience alone is unreal so this is
like the Apple store here's the visitors
center I feel like I should buy
something can i buy something what if I
can buy things here can you buy things
here can today we can buy things I'm
gonna buy some things that can oh my
goodness that to set three cars we are
running low on a stock 40 - I'll do that
- well I did a little bit of shopping
but a little bit oh yeah just a little
which means I'm probably gonna have to
do an unboxing on the Apple Campus
because that not gonna be the coolest
thing ever I think it is so I'm going to
do an unboxing right now on this
beautiful Apple watch fans and I've been
having my eye on some of these bands for
a really long time and I thought it only
appropriate that I buy it here at this
place and I am ops of you too so let's
go
there's like wait where's the bomb
there's the p.m. oh here it is oh so
beautiful
they have these really cool postcards
there's three different versions and
each one a several different postcards
in each box
here's some Apple playing cards
okay these are cool look at this
they're very slick
[Music]
[Applause]
looks so great let's apply a boxing I
got a few other goodies but I'll wait
till later to open this up you wanna
introduce yourself yes hello I'm Alex
null and I'm developing an app for
people with disabilities navigate public
spaces and find safe reliable services
and employment opportunities I'm here at
The Ellen DeGeneres Show that is so
exciting is this your first Apple event
yes I'm so excited to be here yes this
is my first one too guys that brings
this day to a close we are now leaving
the prestigious Steve Jobs theater it
was pretty much the coolest thing it
that I have ever seen
I've waited I'm not even joking more
than half of my life I was probably 10
or 11 when I first realized that there
was this thing called keynotes where
they announced new products and Here I
am today many many years later for the
grand opening of the Steve Jobs theater
I'm so happy I see
[Music]
this roll in
some time to cry